destitute still dirty
and splattered with blood cyren and her
elderly husband have no home left
and no business and right now they feel
there's very little to live for
if what if i was older i will not stay
here never
this is not a country not a country
i was leading from half past six
still help us then no hospital accepting
all the people are on the street
like so many of beirut's residents
they've been up all night
protecting their property often for
these people
it's simply because they've nowhere else
to go
as dawn broke over this devastated city
there was sheer
exhaustion as well as shock
this is what it's like for literally
miles
around every building
every cafe and bar every
home has been left like this destroyed
and in bits
with many people left homeless
this was the moment an explosion ripped
through the city's port
and devastated neighborhoods for miles
around
the shock wave was felt all over the
city a place
so scarred from decades of conflict had
never seen anything quite like this
before
nearly 3 000 tons of ammonium nitrates
which had been stored at the port
for six years exploded with a ferocity
many likened to a nuclear bomb
[Applause]
the stream of sirens from emergency
services was constant
for thousands of people at home or at
work there was no warning
and no way to get to safety only utter
shock
at the magnitude of this disaster
i was fishing i heard that there was a
fire i turned and started to head home
and heard something explode then this
happened i got injured
i didn't know anything
security forces were mobilized across
the city closing off roads leading to
the site of the blast
everything here has been torn apart
homes businesses
banks so much of it reduced to rubble
hospitals across beirut are struggling
to cope
many thousands have been injured they're
still counting them
and locating the dead
i went to another hospital and they told
me were at full capacity
i saw a man whose leg had been cut off
and a boy
who was looking for his parents so i
thought to myself my injury is minor
and hospital has more to deal with
medical services in the country
already buckling under the weight of
coronavirus cases
and shortages in medicine and equipment
are now dealing with a national
catastrophe
two weeks state of emergency has been
declared by the president
every one of our crew doctors and nurses
are operating even administration
everyone is working we have a lot of
damage as you can see
all the ceilings have collapsed at the
entrance and the glass windows of the
patient's rooms
it's hard to see how lebanon can
withstand this it was already suffering
the worst economic collapse
in its history plunging hundreds of
thousands into poverty
many more will now be added to this list
the prime minister has vowed those
responsible for this
will be brought to justice but right now
beirut is just struggling to get through
another day
with tens of thousands of lives
devastated by this tragedy